what's up fellow Geeks we have the iPad
Pro 12.9 inch Edition on here it has the
M2 Chip and we're using the one terabyte
with 16 gigs of RAM Edition and we're
gonna be running some games today on
this thing Call of Duty against impact
pubg mobile and Apex Legends so let's
see how this fares with the tests and
also just before we start we are
shooting this in 1080P 100 FPS we're
gonna check the temperatures on the
front
nice and low 30.
everywhere else
it's up here
29 inch though
30 years one year
nothing to alarm me of course
it's our first game pubg
nice all right so what we get to one of
that let's just go to the settings real
quick so the funny thing is a lot of
these aren't available for the iPad Pro
12.9 just yet because you know I don't
think they put around to optimizing the
game for it just yet but at least we've
got a high frame rate on here everything
else is pretty much on the highest so
let's just jump into a match because
before the match starts just a quick one
still
writing below anything that would be too
concerning but yeah it's actually not so
bad
let's check the back
still nothing to be concerned about
it's pretty alright
let's check that out
see whether it's looking good
and let's see where
we're gonna go and watch everyone
following me never mind
[Music]
okay
it's not super eggy
and nothing maybe is
breaking or anything just yet
but it is pretty smooth I was expecting
the thing to like you know have more FPS
drops here and there but it's still okay
that's good
oh they will
foreign
let's just get this
there you are
grenade
foreign
foreign
[Laughter]
foreign
but here right now because you know it's
great to play on this thing I don't feel
any difference from the time I started
this off and we started at 100 for
battery right now we are at still 100
and it's been like what a solid 15
minutes
so yeah
doing pretty well
foreign
right now while we wait to get to Blue
let's just check temperatures real quick
32
31 32 33 around here somewhere
honestly this still isn't too bad I mean
pubg isn't super graphically intensive
like Kenshin so I'm not really expecting
a lot
in terms of temperature change
yeah
holding up very well of course
and obviously like you know there wasn't
any like
super obvious favorite drops or anything
so I think we're good to go
and a lot of company
oh he was alone
also I think pubg has been running
pretty smooth so far so let's just do
like a final temperature check before we
end this off and move on to the next
game
ah no real
big frame rate drops or anything it's
running pretty smooth I'd say pubg at
this state especially since the higher
graphical settings aren't optimized for
the iPad Pro 12.9 yet you know it's it
runs well
and heat management wise it's doing
pretty okay
I'm in the back it's barely baking 40
and I honestly do not feel any
difference from the time I started this
match all the way up to now so I think
it's safe to say pubg runs well on the
iPad Pro 12.9 with an Android chip so
let's just move on to the next game Call
of Duty
[Music]
oh boy
yeah as you can see you know it's not
really optimized for the iPad but
whatever we can see it all cinematic
here look it's messy clear clear
ly
so yes
um the major looks really good here look
at that
obviously can't do that but yeah she
looks really good
physics and everything excuse me from
here
and the jacket as well
damn good actually okay check the
settings
Graphics very high
can't have but let's do ultra and I
can't put Ultra frame rate on the
highest Graphics at things so
I'm gonna go with
Ultra and this thing
it's the other pans out nostalgic let's
put it through Dynamic you know
realistic sorry
and multiplication
oh yeah so you can turn everything on
because of the ultra frame rate so let's
just run with this and see
how it goes
oh that is very smooth
ly smooth actually
yeah like with all iPads you know this
would take some getting used to unless
there's some sort of gaming peripheral
take your link up both your iPad or your
iPhone to control those sorts
if not yeah
it's going to be a bit of a challenge
but it's fine
right now
standby
UAV online
enemy Advanced UAP is ready Advanced uh
they are um still no difference no free
Range Rover to see running pretty smooth
I don't feel like I said any difference
from the time I started this match
all the way to now so
he's looking up
again just need to know what that card
isn't the most graphically intensive
game on the market
together with pubg so
yeah and that's a match let's just check
the thing okay it is warming up just a
little bit like the tiniest bit here I
do so let's just check it out
yeah 30 3.9 31
increasing 33
nothing to write home about so this is
doing pretty well
33
34
yeah nothing too crazy
nice work
34 here as well
it's doing pretty fine actually so
before we get to the next game we are
actually at 94 right now which is crazy
because we just ran pubg and Call of
Duty on the highest or the most
optimized things for Call of Duty 6 at
least so yeah let's just move the next
game but before that let's talk about
today's sponsor this video is brought to
you by MSI meet the summit E6 in flip
flip the latest 12th gen interact 7
processor
graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD Plus
touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
right our next game we're still at 94
coming hard from Call of Duty so let's
go with Apex Legends
foreign
yes let's play a match weird okay
whatever
all right it's a bit bright
let's do it now let's check our settings
real quick
so graphics and audio
I can't do original so this is try
extreme HD yep uh firming Ultra yes why
not it's moving
FPS because we can do that here
let's turn everything on because we can
and
whatever so everything's on highest
let's just move into a game
holding experience pretty smooth so far
[Music]
where should we go
ah [ __ ] yeah let's go water treatment
actually
yeah cool
okay
all right launching off
looking pretty smooth
well rendering anything is pretty good
that's mostly because of the lag but
other than that it's fine too Daisy but
yeah it's actually okay
[Music]
look off
[Music]
um
no gun [ __ ]
and I'm missing all my shots great
cools
all right let's see how the executions
are like
[Music]
pretty smooth
all right so far looks pretty good well
it actually looks amazing uh no frame
rate drops whatsoever even doing
engagements and heat wise actually doing
pretty well
I'll check back
I want to see you
oh
[Applause]
be quiet so far so let's just use this
opportunity to check for the
temperatures
34 35
a lot more a bit more
compared to the other titles we played
36 here
did I see that right
somewhere on you all right hold on
hold on
thank you
[Music]
I'm training him but I'm not
foreign
reload them
so other than temperature and everything
you know it's a bit finicky to get
around if you don't use your UI
package being delivered let's go this
way
come on
okay
[Music]
it's all Squad
oh okay one yes
so with that let's just check the
temperatures so far no firmware drops
when he thinks the playing of the
highest frame rate setting available
33 35
nothing too crazy like we've seen in the
past three yeah well
yeah okay it is kind of warm here but
it's not uncomfortable or anything let's
check the back
six
yeah really honestly nothing super crazy
nothing to complain about the frame rate
is doing very well actually so with that
let's just move on to the next game all
right next game is Genji impact and
coming in hot from
Apex Legends we are at 83 right now so
let's just move on
nice
okay let me check if it's too private
camera give it a bit
so we are in Kenshin right now and let's
just check the settings real quick
all right graphics and yep let's set the
highest custom
well it'll set to the highest but on the
custom I just put everything else on
high so let's just do and everything
down
yes highest and it's still 60 FPS no
120.
that's why this entire thing shot 100
FPS
called SDS on high
yeah but we're not really gonna be
bothered with that so whatever and then
let's see motion blur do I want extreme
now let's put the let's put yeah it's
pretty extreme why not all right so with
the feedback from you guys we are gonna
go to Inazuma to check out the city and
tomorrow's Forest during this run so so
far
I mean it'll extremely drop right there
doing a Sprint let's just head over to
Inazuma
see how fast fast traveling is
okay not too bad
yep it's just a little bit of hearing a
drop but I don't think it's that bad
wow this looks really good
crowd density here is pretty well dense
so honestly it's not too bad
let's just try going on the city a bit
more
so about characters
only drops in between that's good
all right nothing too crazy
[Music]
honestly
it's fine
foreign
so since we sort of covered in a Zuma
City
we're gonna we're gonna go over to
samir's Forest
I think I'm gonna visit us since then
we'd explored that much
oh
let's try again to a fight in the open
world
[Music]
all the enemies are pretty smooth
yes
no real big frame rate drops or anything
games running damn smooth actually
all right
let's see how the development does
Julio's that was smooth
out
yeah so let's just go to ubis and do
something real quick and see how it fans
in larger scale fights
yes
kill everyone real quick
so far so good so smooth
and I guess the reason why I haven't
really checked temperature yet is
because I haven't felt a huge enough
difference between when we first started
the game and now
fallen leaves
Let's Roll
thank you
coming through
all right so with that let's check the
temperatures
and 30 31
not too bad actually 34 33
doing pretty well I think it's because I
mean like for all the games incremental
graphically intensive ones like Apex and
genjin the largest of this area does
help there's a bit heat pretty well I
believe so honest it's not even crazy
you look at 32 33 nothing's even like
bordering 40 or even the higher 30s
let's check the bag let's begin you know
this is freaking chin
compared to the other iPads and tablets
and mobile phones we've used for these
gaming tasks
I think this is one of the better ones
this definitely is one of the better
ones let's handle
um heat pretty well
so I guess with that let's go
to our final
conclusion in our final thoughts so I
really do have much to say about this
iPad other than the fact that it looks
fantastic with all the games we've
played from the least graphic intensive
ones I say card and pubg besides pubg's
case called look pretty damn good
looking into the menu screen and even
the rest of the game I'm going through a
match as well so that's a pretty big
thing for me I mean okay fine given that
we couldn't get the highest graphical
settings because I don't think it's
optimized for this M2 Chip yet or
basically the device itself so it
handled itself pretty well into the heat
management when it came to Genji and
Apex which is basically just all the
games in general for the BRS and genjin
especially genshin which I'm quite
surprised about very minimal frame rate
drops and everything the whole all the
games run smooth especially during gen
when it came to the bigger fights and
even the bigger areas like Siri on you
know Zuma Aaron Summers Force so again
this is the iPad Pro 12.9 inch Edition
with one terabyte and 16 gigs of RAM
this one is an M2 Chip so if you guys
have any questions about the iPad leave
them in the comment section down below
make sure to follow us on all of our
socials and don't forget to like And
subscribe to us and helps us out a lot
and if you like this kind of content
check out our other videos here
[Music]
thank you